comment ça va très bien merci à vous
parlait bien français c'est génial un
peu je suis canadien bah oui vous êtes
d'ottawa oui exact marche vous faire un
aveu paul le premier disque que j'ai
acheté dans ma vie c'est ça
[Musique]
alors c'est une chanson vous aviez
écrite en 1956 quand vous étiez encore à
ottawa pour une dénommée diana ayoub non
vous étiez amoureux mais oui c'est vrai
que j'étais amoureux d'elle alors c'est
diana pour qui vous avez écrit cette
chanson éternelle vous avez jamais
réussi à conclure avec elle non non non
non non c'est qu'aucun rapport sexuel
rien
si j'avais pu faire l'amour avec elle et
je ne serais pas assis avec vous ce soir
je n'aurais eu aucune raison d'écrire
cette chanson c'est vrai alors cette
chanson a été un énorme succès 10
millions d'exemplaires vendus et vous
êtes devenu l'idole des adolescentes une
vidéo de thierry ardisson par la même
occasion ensuite tu auras ça
[Musique]
mieux
la toiture
ensuite vous avez écrit les paroles
anglaises de comme d'habitude et c'est
devenu ça
[Musique]
c'est long
mon
pas du tout hello
et
c'est aussi devenu ça
et puis vous avez écrit ça pour tom
jones et ça je ne le savais pas une très
belle chanson
ok
arrêté
m
voilà paul anka 9 centimes
60 millions de 10 50 ans de carrière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
doutant cas avec un disque étonnant ce
sont des reprises de tubes des années 80
et 90 alors vous avez appelé le magazine
de classement américain billboard et
vous leur avez demandé quels étaient les
titres qui étaient les les plus tu
baisses que disons puis vous avez fait
des petits des petits ronds autour comme
ça et vous avez enregistré en swing
alors c'est très drôle et des reprises
de bonnes joues vie de héros m200 garden
d'oasis tu de van halen de nirvana paul
anka reprend nirvana nature
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et dieu sait rien non être hélas
hello
à massy il
willow
[Musique]
c'est la piste est
extraordinaire parce que
vous avez décidé de prendre finalement
les classiques d'aujourd'hui les
orchestrer en swing donc il ya plein
d'autres titres formidable didier
durant l'année
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
saint
john
watchguard
ma grande somme de
oh tu clames
oh
je crains
[Musique]
nous sommes rendus au cas
pas chaud
tous les
à gros seins
odieux club
en tout cas
ben tiens
maggio homme banal
[Musique]
janka
et
ah bon et les
afp
il me
faut
lâcher
ce
soir
les ans paul anka rock swing
[Applaudissements]
bon concert le 25
au palais des congrès messieurs voilà
[Applaudissements]
alors
en fait vous avez eu un peu pendant qu'à
la même enfance que josiane balasko et
robbie williams c'est dans le restaurant
que tenez votre père à ottawa la la
locanda que vous avez commencé
finalement à faire le pitre très jeune
et essayer de vous faire remarquer non
oui j'ai commencé d'abord par travailler
au restaurant
et j'ai passé six mois sous la neige au
canada et je me suis rendu compte que
j'avais vraiment pas envie de travailler
dans la restauration
alors c'est vrai que vous étiez pas un
enfant comme les autres dès votre plus
jeune âge vouliez devenir chanteur
vouliez devenir auteur de chansons vous
aviez un ego surdimensionné vous y
croyez vraiment par exemple un jour vous
vous piquez la voiture de votre mère
alors vous n'aviez pas le permis pour
aller participer à un concours de chant
vous faites aussi un concours organisé
par des marques de soupe en boîte pour
pour gagner d'argent problème new york
enfin vous étiez pris à tous quoi pour
sortir de là et pour devenir un chanteur
un auteur de chansons
il faut que vous compreniez bien que
dans les années 50 la musique rock on
était vraiment à ses tout premiers pas
ça n'était pas le showbiz tel
qu'aujourd'hui parce que quand on est
jeune
dans les années 50 il suffisait de
croire en vous ça suffisait et donc je
faisais tout ce que je pouvais pour
pouvoir avoir la possibilité de
continuer et je qui paie juste à la
frontière du québec et de l'ontario et
au québec
c'était ouvert toute la nuit vous
pouviez avoir les femmes les alcools vos
amusé comme un fou toute la nuit et
c'est là que je voulais être donc c'est
vrai que j'ai chiper la voiture de ma
mère savait 16 ans elle dormait et je
suis passé de l'autre côté de la
frontière au québec et puis j'ai
participé à un concours c'est le seul
endroit qui était ouvert où je pouvais
encore à les chanter donc c'est là que
je me suis un petit peu fort mais si
vous voulez au québec alors après vous
allez à culver city enregistré une
chanson ça marche pas très bien vous
revenez au canada enfin si c'est très
compliqué parce que évidemment il
fallait vous faire accepter par le par
le show business et puis vous arrive est
allé à new york vous fait écouter votre
chanson diana et à l'âge de 16 ans vous
enregistrez votre votre premier disque
il ya 50 ans de sa
première fois que suis allé à new york
entre temps nous n'avions pas beaucoup
d'argent dans ma famille donc il fallait
que je me débrouille comme je pouvais et
il y avait une petite annonce dans un
journal local et ça disait si vous
collectionnez des emballages de soupe
campbell vous allez gagner un prix si
vous êtes celui qui collectionnait le
plus grand nombre d'emballages donc je
suis allé dans un supermarché du côté de
chez moi pour pouvoir être à côté de la
soupe et à côté des femmes qui achètent
la soupe et j'écrivais le nom de toutes
les femmes qui achetaient la soupe et
j'allais chez elle et je leur demandais
de me donner les emballages je mettais
mon nom et objets envoyés ça dans une
enveloppe donc j'ai gagné dans mon
district à moi et avec ça j'ai pu aller
à new york il y avait 40 autres gamins
du canada qui sont partis à new york
vous êtes devenu donc très riche très
célèbre et très séduisant vous avez dû
avoir des tas de femmes dans votre vie
non
ja oui
autant que je pouvais en avoir on va
faire une interview ce texte aucun d'eux
paul anka
combien de filles avaient voulu en même
temps dans votre lit
le maximum
fort ah oui c'est bien ce mega mega en
même temps c'est à las vegas ouais faut
quand même savoir un grand lit surtout
enfin
c'est pas de lit osaka quel est le
meilleur endroit pour faire l'amour
d'une femme
[Applaudissements]
quel est votre phrase favorite pour
aborder une fille paul
everitt à vrai dire je n'ai pas de
répliques comme ça tout fait
il suffit de regarder quelqu'un dans les
yeux et puis il ya une chimie il ya
quelque chose qui se passe il vaut mieux
ne rien dire plutôt que de dire quelque
chose d'idiot est ce que ça vous
intéresse que la fille un orgasme à
chaque fois
[Rires]
que je joue mieux est ce qu'il vous
arrive paul de faire l'amour tout seul
vous parlez de masturbation
traître se fini tout ça à l'époque avait
pas que diana liu xia
alors là derrière neuf jours
après une fois qu'on a connu le succès
qu en se masturbant - la vie devient
beaucoup plus facile et plus on est
célèbre on se masturbe c'est vrai est ce
que vous êtes déjà partis de chez une
fille juste après avoir fait l'amour
lorsque ce avec le mari était sur le
point d'arriver oui
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui est ce que vous préférez
bien manger ou bien faire l'amour
vous savez moi j'ai développé une
philosophie récemment et je me suis dit
que je mangeais trop
donc je préfèrerais faire l'amour ça
dure plus longtemps car pas c'est vrai
est-ce que vous avez besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour ou de faire l'amour
pourrait mais
non je n'ai pas besoin d'aimer pour
faire l'amour
l'amour vous savez
plus on vieillit plus on se rend compte
à quel point c'est complexe donc je n'ai
pas besoin d'aimer pour faire l'amour
vous préféreriez qu'une femme vous
quitte pour un homme pour une autre
femme
la zone al aucune importance
ça ne me dérange pas est ce que vous
préférez que la lumière soit allumée ou
éteintes
éteinte de préférence mais bon c'est un
petit problème d'électricité peu importe
quelle est la zone la plus érogène chez
vous
parle la réponse évidente c'est pas
celle là
tout le monde cherche
avec laquelle des personnes ici
présentes vous aimeriez avoir une
aventure paul charlotte quand faut y
aller faut y aller
oui moi
à vrai dire j'ai beaucoup aimé la façon
dont il vous a embrassé
de la rose accord
très bien quelle chance rien ne manque
encore 2 ou encore let's get five tu es
vous avez combien de deux grands amours
dans votre vie
très grand amour
3 4 vous avez pleuré pour des femmes
everyone je crois que tout le monde
devrait pleurer
c'est très bon pour la santé de pleurer
mais je crois que les hommes ne
devraient pas avoir peur de pleurer je
trouve que c'est magnifique lorsqu'une
femme
je crois que les hommes ne devraient
jamais dire aux femmes de ne pas pleurer
[Applaudissements]
vous avez combien de relations
homosexuelles dans votre vie paul
n'y a aucune aucune
mais je n'ai pas vu l'homme qu'il me
fallait
été bloquée thème
[Musique]
il y a
c'est
une question purement total soldats y
ont
été les plus animés valentin bertin
equities pas dans la voix chante faux
c'est terrible j'aurais jamais pu faire
des carrières de paul anka en tout cas
je vais vous faire un aveu
quand j'étais petit que j'achetais diana
j'aurais jamais pensé vous voir un jour
sur un plateau de télévision en face de
moi et je remercie ce métier de me
permettre ça ça me fait très plaisir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
auditive abonnez vous y mettez un peu de
bleu